you say that children don't impact our
happiness positively I mean that's a
data what are you going to do and that
kind of got me worried I have to say Dr
tally Sherritt a leading expert on human
decision making optimism and emotion her
Ted Talk has received over 14 million
views I'm going to talk to you about
optimism kids and children their
happiest and the most optimistic then it
goes down and reaches Rock Bottom in
your midlife
laughs
I'm 30 now so I'm heading right down to
Rock Bottom as we speak
um any advice yes absolutely so one of
the startling things is you talk about
how one tiny move up on the optimism
scale is worth an extra 33 000 a year in
salary it's quite something so Optimus
this is what they usually do if
something went well they usually
interpret that as something about them
that caused this positive outcome
pessimists do the exact opposite I got
the job but really because they didn't
have any other candidates is that
negative explanatory style the road to
depression there's a really tight link
between depression and pessimism the
question becomes well how do I enhance
optimism so there's a few ways to do it
I was thinking that everything you do is
for happiness the happiness is actually
one of three factors that matter so one
is happiness the second is meanings and
then there's a third Factor that's also
really interesting which is
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
tally
[Music]
on the back of your book here the
optimism biased it says you're one of
the most Innovative neuroscientists at
work today
how would you sort of Define or
categorize your own professional
background
so I'm I guess I call myself a cognitive
neuroscientist which is really a mix of
Psychology and Neuroscience and I'm
mixing behavioral economics as well
um so it's it's really a mix of of all
of that so I'm interested in how why
human behave the way that they do
um and why do they have the thoughts
that they have and the feelings that
they have and I think to understand that
you do want to understand what's going
on inside the brain
um but then there's other fields that
give you a lot of really interesting
insights including psychology
um and behavioral economics even things
like law as well sociology philosophy so
it's it's really a kind of
interdisciplinary
adventure and you studied both
neuroscience and psychology at
University and posts grad yeah so I did
my undergrad in economics and psychology
right and in fact I did that because at
the time Neuroscience was not available
for an undergrad degree in Israel in the
whole of the country uh so that wasn't
even an option yes this was a kind of a
long time ago
[Laughter]
um and then for my PhD I did cognitive
Neuroscience which is neuroscience and
psychology mixed together what was
compelling on a personal level to you
about studying those topics why of all
the things you could have pursued why
those things then very early on I was
just really interested in human behavior
right it's about understanding yourself
but also understanding other people
around you
um and you know I think it's one of the
most intriguing topics and and the brain
was kind of a mysterious kind of organ
that is orchestrating all of that
um so I think it was just in an interest
in the world around you and people in it
oh there's some like you know when you
started studying neuroscience and
psychology were there some like
fundamentals about the nature of life
and the nature of human beings that um
I'm ensure there's so many of them but
were there any like real fundamentals
that were
um debunked or reversed as it relates to
your own personal perspective whether
it's about personal responsibility or
about
um an agency or autonomy about how much
control we have about how much influence
we have over our happiness were there
anything foundational that had a real
impact on your personal life
you know there's one thing that recently
is just it's just something that I
recently changed my mind on and that was
actually while writing the current book
that I'm writing which I'm writing
together with Cass Einstein
um who is the co-author of nudge and it
was actually in fact about happiness
because and I remember this clearly I
was in a workshop at the LSC and they
did a survey they asked who thinks that
happiness is the most important thing
right that everything you do is for
happiness and you know everyone had to
stand on a scale if you think like it's
all about happiness stand here and if
you think it's not at all stand here and
I was standing here I was thinking
anything that we do we do for happiness
and that all that and that matters and
while writing this book actually we both
came to the conclusion and for me it was
a change of mind
the happiness is actually one of three
factors that matter
um so one is happiness the second is
meaning
a lot of things you do because it gives
you meaning and it doesn't necessarily
give you happiness sometimes the two go
hand in hand right but sometimes it
doesn't
um so you could do work that's
meaningful and it doesn't necessarily
give you happiness and sometimes it does
and then there's a third Factor that's
also really interesting which is called
a psychological rich life which is
basically variety
a lot of people just do things for
diversity for variety to try a lot of
different things and again sometimes it
goes hand in hand with meaning and
happiness but sometimes it doesn't and
that kind of explains why many times we
make choices that we understand is not
necessarily going to gain us more
happiness but it will gain us some other
thing one of these two other things that
together I think is what brings a good
life
right and that that is something I think
I changed my mind on that it's we're not
actually motivated for happiness
um probably defined as a good feeling
kind of joy
why variety why do humans care about
having Variety in their life
I mean there's kind of the unconscious
evolutionary reason give me that one
um so I think it's exploration right to
move forward both as an individual and
as a society we have to explore a lot of
different things
some of these things are not necessarily
going to give you happiness immediately
or for you at all but a lot of times if
you explore a lot of things you will
find something that is going to be very
important maybe for yourself maybe for
our species I always give kind of you
know the really simple example of
um our ancestors leaving Africa to
explore the rest of the world right they
had I mean why would they do that I mean
either they thought there was something
better for them to find right and it was
probably very hard to do but that's just
kind of an example of exploration right
you're trying different things
um and I I can see it in my own life
right I often do something and then I
kind of okay I had enough with this
let's try something else and so variety
is kind of a factor that I'm trying to
maximize it's kind of a balance right
it's exploration and exploitation right
so you need to do a little bit of
exploitation because you found something
that works and something that you're
good at you don't want to just leave it
be but on the other hand if you just
stick with one thing you may be missing
a whole other a lot of different things
like farming and hunting it's like the
analogy I think from that book who Moved
My Cheese when I think about
um variety my brain was going well I
know some people that get so caught up
in their comfort zones that they never
go exploring and so the the thought that
we'd be motivated or fulfilled by
variety by new things by Adventure
seems to sit in conflict with a lot of
people that I know that are like stuck
in a situation and um maybe not happy
but they're they're more confident than
known than they are leaving that place
and and uh venturing out right because
exploration is risky because there's
uncertainty you don't know what's going
to happen risk means that there's a high
likelihood of both good and bad and you
just don't know where it's going to go
um and so that can cause fear
um uncertainty is a state that usually
people don't like and don't enjoy
um and that's definitely something that
keeps you in place and in fact one of
the kind of points that we make is that
um it seems that people are not making
enough change in their life
um that a lot of times if people think
about changing something in their life
maybe it's a relationship maybe it's a
profession it could be something stupid
like you know the color of your hair or
something like that
um there's a great
um fun little study that was uh
conducted by the freakonomic uh Stephen
Levy what he did he wanted to see if on
average making a change when you think
you might want to make a change this is
not just like oh I think you should get
divorced when you're not even thinking
about it but when you're thinking about
a specific change
on average are you more likely to be
happy if you go ahead with a change or
not right and this is a tricky thing to
study because normally you could say
well let's test people let's ask them
how happy they are before and after they
decide to make a change after they made
a change and then also let's do the same
for people who didn't make a change and
and see who's happier that's not going
to work because people who just to who
go on and make a change they probably
had more reason to do it right so it's
not kind of a good experimental design
so he wanted to randomize whether people
are going to make changes or not so what
he did is
he had people go online and he asked
them are you thinking about a change and
it could be small and it could be big
and they said what the change was and
then he had them flip a virtual coin so
heads you go with a change you know you
take the new job tails you don't
um the likelihood that people would
change if they got the heads the change
was 25 more than the people who didn't
so basically people were thinking about
a change they did it they flipped the
coin if they got they changed they're
more likely to have a change and indeed
people who went actually and and
committed and and did the change were
happier than people who didn't so that
kind of suggests that we're probably not
making enough changes than we should be
um potentially because it's scary right
trying something new is scary and
sometimes it's not going to work I think
that's so much in friends of mine in
like lots of DMS from young people who
are in a situation where they're it's
certain but it's miserable and they have
a they have a potential option to like
go through that dark
Chasm to this potentially better place
but they're choosing to stay in that
certain miserable situation whether it's
a relationship a job whatever it might
be
and I've always I've always felt that
our relationship with uncertainty has a
huge
um sway on our overall outcomes and what
I mean by that is people who are okay
with jumping into that sort of dark hole
where they where there isn't certainty
about their outcomes and just persisting
because they'd rather not be in certain
misery end up having better lives but I
don't know how to get people to have a
better relationship with uncertainty I
mean that's a compelling argument I can
say to them but you know just stats and
facts because I read your books Aren't
Enough there needs to be some kind of
emotional
pitch to them to get them to
diagnose first into uncertainty
um any advice yeah that's a really good
question first of all I mean you're
absolutely right there's individual
differences
um on how comfortable we are with with
uncertainty how comfortable we are with
taking risks
um so I think probably
it would be something like
to some extent helping them through the
change so it might be difficult to
change people's relationship with
uncertainty in a global General way but
perhaps every single time when there's a
specific issue in front of them of what
they want to change
um kind of like helping them along the
way with that change holding them their
hand and you know so to speak
um is probably the only thing that you
could do right to be like I'm here for
you whether it's a friend or a mentor
um we're in their mind in that moment
the thing that's causing the resistance
you describe it as fear right yeah so
what's the opposite of fear is it hope
you know it's not an opposite okay but I
think it is um something that will be
um likely to drive you to take that step
and it's not so much just hope it's
optimism which kind of takes us too yeah
uh some of my research so okay what's
the difference between hope and optimism
so hopped hope is you want something to
happen in the future right I want to get
that job I want to find that
relationship
optimism is believing that I'm likely to
get that job I'm likely to find that
wonderful relationship and it's
absolutely true that if you're
optimistic you think this is going to go
somewhere good then you're more likely
to to go ahead and try that which makes
sense right because my expectation is
going to change my actions and my
actions is going to change my outcomes
right because if I think well I am gonna
I'm gonna try for this competition
because I think I'm I'm likely to to get
something then I go ahead and I try if I
think well there's no no chance I don't
try and so of course I'm not going to
get it so it's a bit of a
self-fulfilling optimism
um and so then the question becomes if I
go back to your question then the
question becomes well how do I enhance
optimism right so there's actually and
and that's it's a good idea because
enhancing optimism will cause you to
take more risk I want to learn how to
enhance optimism and all of my team
members one of my companies so there's a
few ways to do it
um one way is a sense of control we do
have we are more optimistic about things
that we believe we have control over
because we do think that when we have
control that means we can steer the
wheel in the right direction right
um and so if we can cause people to get
a sense that they have control and if
it's about your team is for example
let's say they there's a project that
you want someone to work on
so you can just tell them
to do that project or you can have them
choose to do that project right and you
can guide them to the choice that you
think is correct
but if they believe that they made the
choice that enhances a sense of agency
enhances the change of the sense of
control and they become more committed
to that option
so you can give them oh well there's two
options two projects you can work on
which one do you prefer and again you
can frame it in a way that maybe perhaps
will make them more likely to choose one
or over the other but once they made the
choice it's amazing we've done studies
on this where we give people options for
example going on holiday do you want to
go to France or Rome right Thailand or
Hawaii
if they make a choice there are two
things that are exactly they want it the
same they really want to go Hawaii they
really want to go to Florida but once
they make a choice seconds after making
a choice they now believe that Hawaii is
much better than they did just a few
seconds ago before making a choice and
that Florida is not that great right
because once you make a choice
immediately your preferences change you
rationalize why that choice was great
and now you're more committed to it so
that's true for holidays but it can be
true for work as well right should I
should I go work on on Project A or B if
I make the choice I become more
committed and it doesn't work if someone
else makes a choice for you if someone
else wants a choice for you don't get
into this rationalization mode where you
have to rationalize your choice because
it wasn't your choice and once I feel I
have control then kind of that also
enhances my expectations of how good
it's going to be but it also boosts your
happiness right because I read about the
study in Care Homes where they had an
agency floor in the other floor where
people didn't feel like they had a lot
of agency and choice over their lives
and there was a pretty significant
impact on levels of happiness right yes
so what they did is they gave them some
plans is that is that the study yeah yes
yes yes absolutely so
um when we feel we have control we have
agency that enhances well-being when we
feel our agency has been restricted that
causes anxiety right and this is one of
the reasons that people are quite
anxious on planes it's not just because
we fear the worse but because we have no
control at all right no control about
when are we gonna get there what are we
gonna eat right and that causes a lot of
anxiety
um so by enhancing agency and control
you are lifting people's well-being
happiness and reducing Stress and
Anxiety yeah and those you know that
study with the plants it works with kids
as well right you can give kids some
plans to take care of or have kids make
their own salads um they'll be more
likely to eat it
um so that's just you know a few
examples what could um would you I mean
we don't part of the Innovation team at
any Airline or anything but I was just
wondering in the playing example what
could we do then to reduce anxiety for
passengers I was thinking you know if we
told them before takeoff listen if any
you need to land for any reason well
it's not that we necessarily will but as
you say in that study with the the Care
Homes it's about giving them the
perception that they have control versus
actually giving them control yeah okay
so there's there's a couple of things
that they do
them work
um for also some of the reasons but in a
in a funny way it also enhances sense of
control so one thing that the airlines
do that I think is great is when you can
see the um the the equipments um the
pilot view you know yeah we can see yeah
um that for some I mean obviously you
don't have control but first of all it
reduces uncertainty I mean I really like
to look at that like what height am I in
what year am I going so that and and
although you know you don't have control
that gives you a sense of reduce
sensitivity in some weird way also
enhances a sense of control I have to I
have to say I was on a plane one day
flying I don't want to see the airline
but I was flying and I woke up in the
middle of the night on the plane and I
was it was turbulent and I was convinced
that we were going down I was convinced
I looked out the window and we were
getting closer and closer to the clouds
and I did my quick math we're flying
from New York to London with three hours
roughly three hours into the flight
we're going down that means we're going
down in the sea and I have about 10
minutes on that plane where I have
complete certainly we're getting closer
to the clouds why would we be getting
closer to the clouds and I click on the
little thing that you've described the
little flight map thing and it says
we're at 33 000 feet and we're not
moving and I go okay
I mean whoever thought that was a good
idea obviously understand psychology
um the other thing that that I that I
like that they do
um is actually they did and I mentioned
that in in one of the books
and it's not really related to control
but it relates to another really
important part of psychology which is
so normally at the beginning you know
you're about to go
um to get on the flight
um and they have to go over all the
safety instructions and normally no one
would listen
right because it was all about in the
state of emergency then you have to do
this and that and no one wants to think
about the state of emergency right so
you kind of like shut down they're like
okay Twitter Facebook
um and so what they did is they um and
especially virgin did this
um they switched it so it was very
entertaining very light and it was all
about the destination it was all about
it wasn't about being in the sky and
having an emergency state which is
negative and I don't want my attention
to go there I don't want to think about
it it was about let's think about when
you land and it's going to be the
islands and you know the beach and so on
and they kind of like put the
information that you need to know within
this very light entertaining positive
humorous video and the number of people
that that watched that attended has gone
gone up really uh tremendously and in
fact people started watching it at home
before they even got on the plane right
on YouTube so that's that's another
really um interesting thing and that
goes to another principle
that we find a lot in our work which is
that people
um take in positive information about
their own future much more than negative
information about their own future so if
I'm starting if I will tell you you know
I think your podcast listening numbers
is going to go down you'll be like well
she doesn't know what she's talking
about right but if I say oh I think this
is great and it's only going to go up
more and more with time you'd be like
yeah she's probably right and become
more confident so that's on average
people tend to take positive information
to update their beliefs more than
negative it doesn't mean that we don't
listen to negative information about the
our own future
um but on average we see that you learn
more from unexpected positive
information about the future that's
somewhat
confirm some of the things that I read
in your second book The influential mind
where I remember I was watching a
YouTube video where you were in it and
they were
x-raying is that what they call it when
they look at someone's brain
uh scanning someone's scanning yeah like
in an MRI yeah like an MRI scan and they
were scanning someone's brain
um as you told them that you agreed with
their beliefs versus when you told them
that you kind of disagreed with their
beliefs and when you agreed with their
belief their brain lit up and seemed to
be really receptive and then when you
told them you disagreed with their
beliefs their brain seemed to kind of
just be Frozen and this is really useful
for when you're thinking about having a
conversation trying to influence or have
a conversation with your partner or get
through to someone that starting with
agreeability or something where you you
make them feel heard and seen and
understood is a good way to open them up
to information yeah so this relates to
something that's known as a confirmation
bias so the confirmation bias is our
tendency to look for information that
confirms what we believe and to use
information that confirms what I what we
believe to become even more confident
and even more kind of in our belief and
yeah so we we did a study where we had
people come into our lab in in pairs and
they had to make a financial decision
together in this case they had to assess
the value of a real estate
so they made their decisions and we did
scan their brains at the same time and
they were just in two separate scanners
but they could interact over the Wi-Fi
and they had to they saw like a real
estate and they had to say how much it's
worth and they could see what the other
person said and if they agreed with them
or not and it's exactly what you said
I'm agreeing with you
when they agreed your brain is like when
they agreed
um and they gave them more information
about how confident I am and so on so
when someone agreed the other person's
brain showed activity that suggested
they were encoding the information
coming from the advanced partner they
were using it to update their beliefs
and they were becoming more confident
but when someone disagreed they kind of
as exactly what you said did they shut
down they weren't listening they weren't
using this information you know they
were like well they don't know what they
talk about and they were that's it
um and as you said we feel that like in
in real life all the time you know and
it's it's a problem because really our
kind of instinct when someone disagrees
with us is usually to say well listen
you're wrong let me explain I'll explain
why why you're wrong here look at the
data look at the figures and so on
and what happens the person in front of
us is shutting down a lot of times what
they're doing is that the other person
is trying to think about other reasons
why actually they're right and the other
person's wrong so while I'm talking
you're trying to think about what are
you going to say to you know but if I
start with something where we have
common ground
then you're more likely to listen to me
you're more likely to see me as an
agreeing partner and be more open to
what I'm going to say next and there's
one example that I really like is
actually about vaccines and this was
before covid so it was about childhood
vaccines so a lot of parents uh don't
want to vaccinate their kids because of
the alleged link to autism
um and so usually they would go to the
doctor's office and the doctor said well
look there's no link between the two and
here I'll show you the figures the data
the science and it didn't really work
the parents usually didn't change their
mind so instead there's a group of
scientists that said let's see if we can
go a different route we won't actually
mention anything about what we disagree
which is the relationship to autism
instead we will simply highlight what we
already agree on which is that these
vaccines protect kids from potentially
deadly disease which is not something
that the parents disagreed on but the
whole that seemed to have been forgotten
in the debate right while they were
focusing on what they disagreed on so by
focusing on that on what they agreed on
which is the vaccines will will protect
kids from deadly diseases they were
three times more likely to change the
parents intention of vaccinating the
kids wow so I think this means you know
if we're kind of in a conversation about
should we invest in this company or that
company and we're kind of disagreeing
about something is there a different
route to get get to you know the
decision that we want without focusing
there are there other things that we
agree on that that would take us to the
same point and then there's another
method which is just to highlight the
commonalities between us that's also
helpful
you know perhaps there's something I
mean we have a goal in common we have a
motivation in common maybe there's
something in our background which is
similar and that also always makes
people more likely to listen to you and
to use what you're saying
it's so true I was actually as you were
saying I was thinking about a tweet I
saw the other day where Mark Cuban was
having an argument with someone else on
Twitter and Mark Cuban was going back
and forth with this person and he
started his response to them with wrong
full stop and then made his point and
you see that a lot where you where
someone will start a sentence with I
disagree full stop and then make that
point when that happened I'm just going
to be completely honest because who can
I'm a somebody that is imperfect and
full of fault when someone does that
with me when they literally start a
sentence with wrong or I disagree it's
instant combat right and like I'm well
aware of it so maybe it doesn't come up
as much in me but I remember I can go
but I can remember three years ago where
I was when someone said to me when we're
having conversation and they went wrong
full stop and then they made their point
regardless of what comes next it's
combat the minute you do that the minute
you kind of close the door and like pull
up the drawbridge which is exactly what
that sentiment does it's combat from
then on it's like it's this war of
proving that you're right and that's not
helpful for either party right it takes
someone with a certain self self
security I guess and
um not not fragile ego to be able to
to be able to be greeted with that
um sort of conflict and turn to what we
have in common and what we agree on
first but it's a real it's a real
powerful skill for someone to master so
if you're disagreeing with me for me to
you know I like this as well with my
relationship
because me and my partner we might not
agree on something we might we might we
have like very fundamentally different
beliefs about the world she's very
spiritual and very sort of scientific
and how I think
but I know that I get through to her
when I first
understand how she's feeling I don't
have to agree with it but even if I
understand how she's feeling and kind of
like validate her anything that I say
next seems to get in behind if that
makes sense yeah so I mean the
difference is that what you're doing in
the last kind of example is you're using
what we call theory of Mind Right theory
of mind is our ability to kind of think
about what other people are thinking or
feeling so basically take the point of
view of the other person right if and
and there's a huge variability in the
ability of people to do that there's
like tests relatively simple tests
actually that can measure your ability
to do that
um and so if you do that the likelihood
that you will answer by wrong is very
very low right the reason we we start by
wrong you're mistaken is because we do
the opposite we come from our point of
view which makes sense because our brain
is here and our eyes are here right so
it makes sense that we come from our
point of a bit from our point of view
it's like this is wrong this is not
right right but of course the best way
to get your message across is to try to
see things from the other person's point
of view and then think like okay what
can I say from that point of view not
from my point of view from that point of
view
um super difficult to do I'm gonna give
an example say my um my partner was
um upset about something and feeling
stressed about something which is just
to do with her environment
and my first response was very like
logical and scientific like and also
psychological like kind of like it's
just in your head which I know it's kind
of gaslighting that's not exactly what I
said before I get canceled but it was
referring to the fact that I I think you
can you can kind of think your way
through this like as if I was trying to
help her feel empowered and not letting
her environment get the best of her now
that didn't work the response there was
like not good my next approach was to
completely understand how she's feeling
and kind of go around her side and say
to her do you know what you're only
going to be here for five minutes anyway
and then it'll be fine and that
completely worked it was like she was
glued on me as I said that and she
looked at me and nodded and went yeah
you're right the first approach of
trying to play like logic and like no no
you know didn't work but then when I
said term I understood but then offered
a solution from that place of
understanding she was really open to it
yeah and that was like an hour ago so
it's in front of mind for me
um yeah so so I think this is a problem
a lot of times with like campaigns like
political but also different campaigns
where people try to
um
get a message across using data figures
logic which are important I mean we need
all the science and we need all the data
to know what's true but once you know
what's true the data is not enough to
convince people of what is true and in
fact the things that work are things
that you're talking about which is
emotion works really well
stories anecdote example right for in
science the worst thing we can do is use
one anecdote right so we don't want to
get a conclusion based on one answer but
in order to get our message across in
fact a single anecdote is really helpful
right
um and to my mind we actually have to
embrace that that's the way the human
brain works right so I mean I think in
if we just go ahead and say well I don't
like that I don't like how the human
break works so I'm gonna give them data
and figures anyway well the message
won't get across right so we really need
to embrace if we understand how the mind
work and then we embrace it to get the
the important information across and
again another example that I kind of
write about is
This was
um years ago with the 2016 campaign
where
um Trump was one of the candidates for
the Republican Party
um and Dr Carson was another and they
were debating and the debate turned
again to the vaccines and autism
question and so they were asked about
you know Trump says that there's a
relationship between childhood vaccines
and autism Dr Carson is a pediatrician
and and he was asked well you know what
do you think about this and Dr Carson
said look this is not true we have a lot
of data we have a lot of Science and you
know I'm sure that if Trump reads the
science and data he will be convinced
otherwise
um so then they turn to Trump to see if
he was convinced and of course he wasn't
convinced but then what he did he used
the absolutely opposite approach which
is he told a story a story of someone
who worked for him who had a little baby
and he said the baby got the vaccine and
he used like to induce emotion he is
like you said it was a horse-sized
syringe right
and after a few weeks the baby got
autism
and now I'm not saying that we should do
we should um communicate false
information using anecdotes and emotion
but me I remember I was actually
watching that and my son was a few weeks
old and he was next to me on the sofa
and I'm a scientist and I know all the
data and you know but still my and I
know that he was wrong but my reaction
was like ooh maybe I should think about
this twice before I decide whether to
vaccinate my little son here
um and I felt like that for at least I
would say like a few minutes a little
bit more and kind of that feeling made
me think look if I'm thinking that
because all because Dr Carson just said
there's data and figures and Science and
Trump just told the story that got me
feeling quite anxious and he was much
more influential
um what about everyone else that's
watching you know people who are not
neuroscientists who don't have training
with science
um and it really kind of hit home how
powerful it is now you could use these
techniques obviously to spread
misinformation and to do harm of course
but if Dr Carson had used some of these
techniques as well he could say there's
a science but together with that you
know maybe using some kind of anecdote
to maybe use some um
hope hope and optimism emotion right
some something like that he would maybe
have caused many many people who are
watching it to vaccinate their kids and
therefore to save lives
um so I think there's like you know if
you don't understand human behavior and
you don't use it because maybe you don't
like it you know you're like you don't
like that that's how the brain works
you'll be missing on something right
this is why conspiracy theories flourish
on social media right because all I need
to do is get one anecdote one low
context video one picture one screenshot
of something and posted on Facebook and
regardless of the science whether it's
climate change or vaccines whatever that
one little screenshot from a telegram
group that says something happened to
one person somewhere out of 8 billion
becomes way more sort of um believable
and plausible and
um powerful than all of the science and
I've seen that over the last couple of
years it's why like the misin for me it
feels like a bit of a losing War really
because
with bringing like facts and figures to
an emotional fight and the facts and
figures just will never win like even
below the you know social media channels
now we're putting the little tag on post
to say well actually Politico says this
isn't true it's like he gives a crap it
hits somebody in the feelings um but it
also speaks to the you know you talk a
lot about this in your book The
influential mind it speaks to how as as
business people or in sales or whenever
we're trying to be heard and understood
or influence others coming with facts
figures graphs and charts is not going
to be as compelling as coming with um
a really great emotional story
I I've always impressed upon people as
much as I can that like your facts and
figures and charts and graphs really
don't really matter when you're trying
to convince people
um and that's what your book really
speaks to right and it's terrible for a
scientist of course
all day is you know gathers gather data
and do analysis but um yeah so so it's
an interesting question so why do these
stories why are they so effective and so
I think there's two major region reasons
one is they are well free actually one
is mostly they induce emotion and what
emotion does it gets you to focus
because emotion tells your brain this is
important right and it gets a whole
brain noticing it's like a little red
kind of light in your brain going
emotion pay attention right so if you
say something that's emotional people
are going to pay attention and they're
going to remember better so emotion
enhances the likelihood that you will
remember things
um then the second reason is if you
think about it how humans how did we
learn right if before we had science
before we had all these ways to get so
much data we would we would live in like
relatively small groups and we would
learn from observing others right
observing like a friend or someone who
lives nearby it was learning from
stories that's how we evolved to learn
from a small n right only now do we have
you know these these techniques and big
data that we could really figure things
out but our brain is still a brain of
these humans that didn't have the
internet that didn't have all the math
that we have now and so we're still
learning from stories that's kind of our
our Instinct now we are sophisticated
creatures we can't overcome this we can
look at the data we can learn but really
our instinct is to learn from a single
story the third reason I think is that
stories are often novel like you've
never heard the exact same story in that
kind of way again novelty causes you to
pay attention and causes you to remember
it's another signal if something is
important right while data and figures
you kind of heard it before if someone
says well there's no relationship
between Autism and vaccine or whatever I
mean you've already had the science it's
usually doesn't it doesn't sound so
novel and really our brain cares about
the headlines right what's new it's like
a newspaper we don't care about what's
been the same we care about this is new
means that we should pay attention and
then maybe it's important or maybe not
but
um that last Point really resonated
about the the cnh that stories are in
essence novel you've never heard about
Debbie in Newcastle exactly before
um but also what you know now it makes
perfect sense as to why politicians in
the house of parliament every week say I
spoke to my constituent Dorothy in
Burnley and then they'll tell the story
about Dorothy struggling to to hit her
home versus just coming with facts and
when you hear about Dorothy who can't
heat her home you feel way more oh my
God versus hearing 24 of elderly people
can't hit their home for example when I
think about motivation though does the
same rules apply so if I want to
motivate my team should I be telling
them the Diary of a CEO has done 20
million downloads this month or should I
be telling them a story of
Dorothy who listened to the podcast and
it changed her life
I think in this case both things will
will work I mean
um seeing progress is something that
really motivates us and seeing progress
with numbers is an easy way for us to
see progress right this is why
um all these kind of like track your
steps work right
um so I think to motivate I mean it's oh
it's always lovely also to hear a story
I mean even for yourself if you know it
doesn't matter how many people watched
your podcast is that when you get like
you meet someone they tell you about
like how much you touch them and really
change their life and they decide to
make a decision because of you they
heard you do something you really
remember that right that like causes so
much joy and motivation numbers are
great too right when you look and you're
like oh I have one million people
listening to my podcast that's great too
so I think both things work and when if
you do use numbers it's really great to
kind of show the progress right a really
great way to change Behavior is to show
people progress and numbers is just one
way to show it right if they can kind of
see it going up up up up
um that's that's really helpful and I
mean we know it in sports but it can it
can be true for anything right if it's
like you can do it it's money
Investments right
um seeing that go up relationships as
well I wonder how you can do it for
relationship it's a good question well I
I actually I say that because I feel
like I do that sometimes with my partner
where um we might be facing some kind of
issue and one of the most compelling
things we've ever done when we're facing
an issue is we look at all the issues
we've overcame together and like how
we're here right so there were so many
other times where we thought this you
know we couldn't solve it she lived on
the other side of the planet I lived
here we both didn't want to move and
then I've had exactly the same situation
that was her problem for years and years
oh really yeah I remember bits being sat
in a bar and my partner was talking
about an issue something that we were
struggling with or whatever and I
remember saying to her like look look
how far we've come from where we were
here to where we are now it's like well
there's nothing that's gonna get in the
way of us you know and that seemed to be
compelling because I guess it was an
emotional story of all these the
previous issues we've overcame getting
back to the optimism bias
the optimism bias from what I understood
is that is that bias to believing that
um the future will be good
is that is that accurate or is that
inaccurate yeah kind of so um optimism
on its own I mean even though I'm wrong
no no
that's right I'll just give you the
scientific definition so um yeah so
optimism is believing that that some you
know that positive things will happen
the optimism bias means that um you're
either like that you believe these
optimistic things these good things will
happen but the evidence suggests
otherwise so it's it's actually a
mistake right the optimism bias so
usually we Define it as overestimating
the likelihood of positive events
happening so you're overestimating
um how much money am I gonna get with my
first job when I leave graduate school
right or overestimating like how long my
marriage will last
um and so on so overestimating the
positive in light of the evidence that
is in front of us and underestimating
the likelihood of negative events
happening so I'm underestimating my
likelihood of getting covered of getting
cancer of being in a car accident going
bankrupt whatever it is based on
whatever evidence is is there
um so optimism bias does mean mistakes
so the word bias means a systematic
mistake
so obviously when we think about the
future we can't be right most of the
time because the future is uncertain we
don't know what's going to happen so
we're going to be wrong a lot of the
times when we predict the future but the
optimism bias means that the mistakes
that we make tend to systematically be
that we expect it to be better than it
ends up being so that's basically the
optimism bias right I expect it to be
better than it ends up being
um which sounds like a bad thing but
it's not necessarily so I mean the word
bias people usually because it is a
mistake people usually think that that
means it's not a good thing but it's not
necessarily so it can actually have both
positive and negative
um outcomes to it so if you think about
the positive
um if I expect good things in my future
specifically good things even though I'm
overestimating the likelihood of these
things happening even if they think oh
I'm you know I'm gonna make one million
in the next year and of course that's
way more than I'm going to
um
but that then motivates you right so
having these positive expectations
motivates you to try harder it's a bit
like I think I'm going to get the gold
I'm more likely to get the silver so
that's kind of the idea and it also
enhances your happiness and well-being
right because how you're feeling now is
a lot to do not necessarily with what
you're doing at the moment but what you
think you'll be doing later right how
you're feeling now is like okay you
might maybe feeling nice talking here
but um a lot of it is what do I think
I'm gonna do later on this evening next
week next month in a year our
expectations of where we will be in the
future affects our happiness today right
and so if I have these positive positive
expectations of the future even if
they're not going to happen they make me
happier today this is why there's a
really cool study that was done at
Harvard where they were asking people
who are about to go on vacation how
happy they were every day before
vacation and have every day during
vacation and every day after vacation
for a week so a week before vacation
every day a week doing vacation every
day a week after vacation every day so
what was the happiest day do you think
the day before they were right exactly
right the day before vacation they were
still in the office right working on the
computers but on their mind they were
already on vacation on the in their mind
it was wonderful and when they went on
vacation it was good but it wasn't as
good as it was in their mind the day
before so it's the anticipation of these
Goods so it's an optimism bias because
they thought the vacation is going to be
better than what it ended up being but
that brought them the happiness before
yeah right and also probably enhance the
likelihood they will go on vacation
which is a good thing
um as well so does that mean that we
should uh in our relationships in our in
our teams Etc we should try and give
people things to look forward to
absolutely absolutely and I think that
there's two things you kind of want
things in the diary right so having a
vacation in the diary that's going to
happen in a month makes you happy today
so whatever it is whatever you're doing
for that matters to your team
have what I call anticipatory events
right things that they could look
forward to that will make them happy
today
um but also I think you know a lot of
times I do motivate my uh Team by
telling them that I think this project
is going to work really well I mean even
I think it's from going pretty well but
I might like exaggerate a little bit
because you know that enhances
motivation and who knows you know maybe
it will work even better than I expected
so it's good to kind of enhance kind of
the the expectations and also to have
these things that people can look
forward to and of course it works the
other way
so also if you're dreading something
that's going to happen tomorrow next
week right you have to go to the dentist
or whatever bad thing is happening is
gonna get there and that it's gonna
affect your mood today
um so dread of things in the future and
anticipation of the good stuff is all
affecting how we feel at the moment
quick from one of our sponsors I've got
a tip for all of you that will make your
virtual meeting experiences I think 10
times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events
Intel one of our podcast sponsors and I
want to talk to you for a second about
their built for business vpro platform
in today's Working World the office is
pretty much anywhere and Intel V Pro
means you can remotely manage repair and
protect devices across your entire
organization no matter how large or
small giving me and my team peace of
mind to work wherever we choose to for
my it team whether on premise or via
Cloud behind the corporate firewall or
not Intel's vpro comprehensive
manageability has us covered this is
something that is so important to me I
you know I'm a huge believer in employee
flexibility and Trust so having features
like this are super helpful so to find
out more search intel.co.uk vpro and let
me know how you get on
how contagious is optimism and
conversely pessimism in like in life
generally if I'm around a group of
pessimists or I'm around a group of
optimists what kind of contagious impact
is there on on me yeah any emotion is
contagious
um anything sadness anxiety Joy
everything is contagious fear
and it happens really really fast and in
an unconscious way right it could be
even like you're sitting in um
in the tube and someone in front of you
is looking fearful
you straight away will will feel fearful
yourself first of all you will mimic the
expression of the person that's in front
of you without noticing it so if you
look fearful I'm going to start
mimicking the same facial expressions
yeah and that facial expression will
make me feel fearful right because our
brain is learning from how our face
right there's it's a signal and it goes
both ways like a feedback loop
um and there's a good reason for it
because if someone is afraid there might
be something dangerous around us so I
should have you seen the main piece in
the David Attenborough documentary that
star they they know that they know that
the other monkeys are taking a cue from
them so they fake fear so they go and
then when all the monkeys run off they
go and get the food
because they've like they've like got to
level two where they realize that
they're all taking cues from each other
and I remember that documentary thinking
wow like you know because all the
monkeys would run the minute one monkey
made a reaction and that's pretty much
what you're describing there right yeah
exactly and it works for good things as
well if someone looks excited you're
like you will feel excited as well you
don't know why but if they're excited
there might be something good around
right
together I'm just thinking about you
it's just mimicking we do facial
expressions we mimic any kind of facial
expression and bodily Expressions as
well yeah I'm trying not to no yeah but
um but okay so why is this really
important to think about because let's
say you want to you're managing your
team if you're stressful and you're
gonna start like I don't know even like
shouting or raising your voice or
they're gonna get more stressed as well
right so it's it's it's true it's a bit
like the monkeys you can actually change
at least X how you look in terms of the
emotions you need to think about what is
my what emotion am I conveying because
the emotion that you are conveying is
going to then affect how people around
you feel
um so there's a little bit of kind of
emotional control
um that is helpful too
you mentioned now that you kind of you
might exaggerate a little bit the
belief in a positive outcome to your
team members and I think that's and I
hope they're not listening yeah well I
think we all do sometimes I mean I
usually believe it because I think I
have a bit of a bias optimism bias
myself but um
that's in part because of I guess
chapter three in the optimism bias where
you talk about how self-fulfilling um
optimism is and there were some really
really staggering
statistical sort of studies and
um experiments that have been done to
prove that optimism really is a
self-fulfilling thing
and it kind of kind of makes me think
about this concept of manifestation
people always talk about manifestation
and it seems that see it's in my mind
always been this kind of pseudosciency
you just think about something and then
it happens what's your view on
manifestation is it true yeah so it's
not magic it's not that I'm thinking
something in my mind and the waves are
gonna change what happens in the world
the reason if you believe something the
likelihood will happen is higher is
because you then change your actions
right you think I think you know my
startup is going to really succeed and
that then changes your actions you're
more likely to go out there and tell
other people right so if you think it's
going to succeed you're more likely to
convey that information to investors and
so on they can see your your kind of
confidence they'll be more likely to
invest in you right you put more time in
you put more effort in
um and that's why it can have an effect
on the the outcomes
so it's not kind of a magic kind of
thing it's just that what we believe in
our mind changes the way we behave and
the way we behave in the world changes
World
um so that's that's why that is that's
kind of like this idea of
self-fulfilling prophecies is linked to
this concept of stereotyping where one
of the real startling things I read in
your um in your work was that if a woman
is reminded of her gender before a math
exam then her performance on that math
exam will drop
right so our expectations where do they
come from right to some extent I mean
they're coming from around us as well
not only we can have like confidence
even if the people around us do not but
other people's expectations whether it
is your friends your family Society will
impact your own
um and so and again that's becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy right if you're
told females are not good in math
they're not good in science they can't
be CEOs and so on
that will change the way that you think
even if it's momentarily even you're
trying to fight it it will change the
way that you think and what you believe
and that will then change
um your outcomes and I think maybe in
that I mean we don't know exactly why um
reminding females about The Stereotype
that the females don't do well with math
changes the exam results but it could be
things like maybe it enhances anxiety
you start self-doubt right I mean if you
go to an exam and there's self-doubt
well that's not helpful
um and there's you know there's all
these classic studies where um
there was in in a class they would tell
the teachers at the beginning of the
semester
um who the talented kids were but it was
random they randomly selected kids and
they said these are The Talented ones by
the end of the year they did better
these kids right because the teachers
believed that they were talented they
would treat them in that kind of way
they would maybe put more time they
could fade their expectations to the kid
the kids and started believing that
they're talented and not give them
confidence and they performed better and
of course it worked the other way right
if a teacher believe is told this is you
know the naughty one this is you know
the non-intelligent one that will then
change
um how the kids behave what they believe
and this is where stereotypes are you
know come into play as well because
sometimes it's about not specific
individuals it's about a whole group of
individuals and one such example as well
as the the study where African-Americans
were found to do significantly worse on
IQ tests compared to Caucasians people
that are white when race was emphasized
before the IQ test
did as well as white people when no
stereotype was mentioned before right
just just by mentioning that I'm black
before I do a IQ test will lower my
performance on the test versus if you
hadn't mentioned it because the
association here you're reminded of
ethnicity and you're doing this exam and
then you know that maybe in your Society
there's a stereotype and again that can
cause self-doubt and anxiety and so on
and what I think I like is that I think
after I I talk about that study I also
talk about another study that after
Obama was elected grades went up
for African Americans
um because it's again it's a
self-confident thing it's amazing how
these you know little things I mean it's
not little the fact that Obama got got
elected is not little but then the fact
that that then impacts your
self-confidence you know the little
impact on self-confidence then changes
um your grades
um it's it's quite something but it also
changes your um one of the other things
I read that's really starting it also
changes your
salary
you talk about how one tiny move up on
the optimism scale is worth an extra 33
000 a year in salary over the long term
right and I okay so that's
um that that shows us a correlation I
think I think that's um so we still
don't know for sure if it is it that
because I have specific traits I'm more
likely to be optimistic and therefore
more likely because of those traits also
more likely to gain higher salary right
so you know you can imagine I'm
optimistic because I had a very
privileged life
um and I did well in school so I'm more
optimistic and and for the same reasons
and then more likely to get a higher
grade
um
but
um in in some cases so we don't know if
it's going one way or the other way
right if it's a causation or correlation
one interesting thing that that has been
found is that optimists are more likely
to be entrepreneurs
there's I mean that is quite clear you
know
um and again we don't know is it because
I'm optimistic that I'm more likely to
be an entrepreneur or is it something
about being an entrepreneur that makes
me more optimistic but what they found
is after you become an entrepreneur you
become even more optimistic right so
that suggests that there is something it
is true that optimistic people are more
likely to take a chance more like to
take a risk and therefore more likely to
be entrepreneurs and that experience of
doing that enhances your optimism
further which is really interesting kind
of goes both ways does that then explain
how we can teach someone to become more
optimistic because if the pursuit of
Entrepreneurship make is kind of
self-reinforcing your optimism it's
making you more and more optimistic one
would assume that that's because you're
gaining evidence about yourself and the
world and what you're capable of as
you're going which is further sort of
fueling you and conversely someone who I
know maybe Ling this too long in their
comfort zone and is
um like leaning out of opportunities
constantly being negatively reinforced
in terms of their self belief in their
skills Etc so they're becoming more and
more pessimistic is that like broadly
true I think it might be yes I think you
are gaining evidence that you can do
things and I think even if you feel
um you still gained evidence that you
were able to try something new right
right and not die and not die right and
you learn something right
um yes I think you're absolutely right
um
so if you're able to get people to have
these kind of experiences
that then causes them to become more
confident that will then enhance their
optimism
so how do you know we talked about the
all the positive upsides there of being
an optimist how does if I've got a
friend that's a pessimist or a partner
or a husband or whatever it might be how
do I get them we talked a little bit
about it there but how do I get them to
become more of a Optimist because I want
to be surrounded by optimists I want my
company to be full of them like
pragmatic optimists but still people
that believe that you know the future is
going to be good
um and we're going to do great things
for all the self-fulfilling reasons
you've described what do I do okay so
first of all I just want to mention that
about 30 of how optimistic we are is
genetically determined this has been
shown from twin studies but that still
leaves two-thirds right
um the um I think the best studies on
this comes probably from Martin Seligman
where he actually did experiments where
he got people who were somewhat
pessimistic even slightly depressed and
the approach that he took is to change
the inter what he calls interpretation
Style
so optimists this is what they usually
do if something happened and it it went
well right you sold your startup for a
lot of money you had a project and it
was successful they usually interpret
that as a meaning that they it's it's
personally it's something about them
that caused this positive outcome right
and it is something in them that's quite
permanent let's say my project went well
because I'm a hard worker right and you
know maybe I'm intelligent or whatever
and then they say well if I have those
skills that means that a lot of other
things are going to work well in life
right if I'm in a hard work or if I'm a
good with good with people that also
means that I'll be a good dad for
example right when something negative
happens they tend to do the opposite
they tend to see it as circumstantial
right this negative thing happened okay
so I didn't put a lot of effort in this
but not because I'm not hard worker I
just didn't put enough effort because I
was distracted by something else or you
know this other person just happen to
have a better better proposal so it's
circumstantial that means that they
don't take that as evidence of how am I
going to perform in the future right so
it's really different interpretation of
negative outcomes and positive outcomes
so what and then pessimists do the exact
opposite when something bad happens they
say this bad thing happened because of
me because of a trait that I have and
because I have this trait let's say I'm
bad with people that's going to affect
all the rest of my life and all these
future projects when something could
happen is circumstantial good thing
happened I got the job but really
because they didn't have any other
people candidates so what Martin segment
did is he taught people this
interpretation style that he taught them
whenever something good happens this is
how you have to think about it you have
to think about it what is it about you
that caused this positive thing to
happen right and how is that positive
trait or whatever skill whatever
everything you did how can it affect
other parts of your life and other few
future outcomes and the opposite for
negative something negative happened I
don't mean it don't take responsibility
but are there circumstantial right it
could be something that you did but it
doesn't have to be permanent right you
happen to have be in a really bad State
because I don't know something else your
parent was was sick or something so he
teaches them the people to kind of
interpret this to find these reasons for
the positive and negative and it seemed
to work
um
to some extent now it's difficult I'm I
mean you know it's not easy to turn a
pessimist into an optimist
um but it had some effect on their
well-being and even on their physical
health as a result is that negative
explanatory style of saying okay this
bad thing happened it's because of me
it's because I'm not good enough
whatever is that the road to depression
yeah so there's a really tight link
between depression and pessimism so
pessimism is a symptom of depression
it's an actual symptom
um and so what we see is people with
severe depression have a pessimistic
bias they expect the future to be worse
than it ends up being and worse than the
evidence in front of them is
um people with mild depression have no
bias at all this doesn't mean they're
accurate they can make mistakes but on
both sides so sometimes they expect
things to be better sometimes they
expect things to be worse but overall
um they don't have a bias
happiness
you know one of the things we talked
about before we started recording was um
Scott Galloway said on this podcast that
happiness looks like a u-shape
throughout our lives as in When We're
Young we're a high level of happiness
and then we kind of dip into our 40s I
think I think from what I read when we
hit our 40s that's kind of the lowest
it sounds kind of moving sounds kind of
a grim but we that's our lowest point of
happiness and then it kind of Curves
back up again as we go into the last
sort of chapters of our life is that
accurate because Scott didn't provide
any research and I've mulled it over and
I you know yeah no so this this is true
it's based on many studies and and
studies involving thousands of thousands
of individuals you know up to like 70
000 or more in a country and it's been
shown in many many countries
um so not just in in the Western World
in many many countries almost all
countries around the world
um so exactly what you said kids and
children their happiest and the most
optimistic then it goes down and reaches
Rock Bottom in your midlife as well as
optimism does so actually in middle age
you stop having an optimism bias so your
optimism is greater greatest in
children's and kids it causes goes down
down and then really there's no optimism
bias in midlife on average of course and
then it starts going up you become
happier and more optimistic until the
last few years of life which is
counter-intuitive to our image of the
grumpy old man right and actually stays
there until the couple last couple years
of life
um the difference between countries is
that the dip the you know the point
where it's lowest actually is a little
bit different between country and
Country I think in the US it's about 40
it's a relatively early I think in the
UK as well but then some countries it's
much uh I think like Italy might be 50
Greece as well like 50 to 60. and then
there's a few countries where you don't
see that Russia is one of them
Romania and I forget there's another one
where you actually don't see they
actually just become you know less and
less less happy
um in those countries we don't know why
that is that specific case I'm 30 now so
I'm heading right down to Rock Bottom as
we speak oh you've got time you've got
time I'm about to turn so I'm way I'm
looking forward
I'm on the way well not quite yet but
I'm about on my way up and this you know
this links to I think chapter five in
your book where we say where you talk
about the chapters called that humans
are bad at predicting what makes them
happy and one of the startling things is
it you say that children
don't impact our happiness positively
now I'm under the impression that
children make us ecstatically happy well
it's difficult but from what I've from
what I've heard from people I thought
children are something to really be
looking forward to but you seem to
assert otherwise in your book
um so this first of all I want to say
this is just a research and the numbers
and um
my I'm not just saying this but my own
experience is the absolute opposite
um bear in mind her child is upstairs
and he's watching this Leo no but but
it's absolutely true because it's funny
because because of that research and I
wrote the first this is in my first book
The optimism bias which I wrote before
my kids and I I actually I mean I
believed it it I mean I mean that's a
data what are you going to do and and
that kind of got me worried I have to
say about having kids I was a little bit
worried about the fact that children it
says children's you know children don't
mean you happy you become less happy you
become less happy when you have children
that's what the research I didn't I
didn't see that oh sorry that's what you
said right because children don't make
you happy yeah right but I didn't know
there was I thought they didn't make you
more happy I didn't know they make you
less oh no it's it apparently like um I
mean the data shows I mean there's a
little different points of data some so
for example there's one piece of data
that shows that this was done by
actually Daniel conman who's a Nobel
Prize winner
um where they asked a large group of
French women to say how happy they were
throughout the day so I don't know every
few hours or oh maybe at the end of the
day they said what they were doing and
how happy they were and they found that
the least happy people are is commuting
but then I think number two least happy
was being with their children
so I have to tell you from my own this
is an anecdote an N of one my children
really make me extremely happy I love
being with them I'm really it's contrary
to all the research so I I truly I mean
I'm surprised you know before they were
born I was thinking look if you know if
I don't like them we'll put them in a
boarding school and my mom was like I
don't think you want to put them in
boarding school you're probably and I
was like well we'll see and then and
then no absolutely love having them
around so but that's just an end of one
so I don't know and of course your own
experience unfortunately even as a
scientist shapes the way that you
interpret the data but um I mean look
having I mean I'm sure having children
can be difficult and and you know it
depends on your life circumstances and
all of that and temperament of the child
and so on and so I'm sure it could be it
could be difficult but is that is that
because there's a distinction as you
said at the start of this conversation
between like happiness and meaning it
might be difficult but it's meaningful I
need like work is difficult there's like
varieties of work if I'm working in a
job with a little autonomy where the
outcomes I'm like subjectively not
interested in then it's just difficult
work but if I'm like raising a child
it's difficult but it's tremendously
meaningful so although I might say to
this the investigator that I'm unhappy
when my kid is crying and running around
and smashing everything and playing with
the Rubik's Cube won't put it down
I reflect on that in hindsight and go oh
amazing
absolutely I mean meaning is important
and you should do things you should make
choices
um according to meaning as well
um
and and obviously there's individual
differences in my case it they just
actually make me happy I can like dance
with them in my you know at home and
like actual happiness
um but but you know it can obviously
it's different it's not like all the
time of course
um what about marriage that was the
other one that was quite surprising that
it didn't didn't make it but I think
okay so that was a little bit so it's
been a while since I look at this but I
think it was nuanced which is what does
make you happy is being in a
relationship I believe that did make
whether you were married or not married
didn't really matter but I think being
in a relationship was was inducing
happiness the other kind of interesting
finding about that is that
um how fast people get over divorce
right that it takes I mean I don't know
if it's fast or not but within like so
just before
um a few years before you get divorced
happiness starts going down because of
course there's problems I guess and so
on and it actually hits Rock Bottom just
about the time that you get divorced and
then then it starts going up you start
adapting right and in fact goes back to
Baseline levels of happiness within
about two years I don't know maybe maybe
two years is a lot but then people uh
bounce back
um so when you kind of think about these
changes which could be negative right
divorce
I think people don't consider as much
our ability to adapt so fast right to
change so fast I think covet was a
really good example of the pandemic I
mean before the pandemic if I was to
tell you you're going to have to stay at
home and not see anyone else and you'd
be like this is disaster how's it going
to happen
um people adapt it quite fast yes stress
we did studies we actually started doing
studies a few weeks after the pandemic
started we did see of course Stress and
Anxiety was enhanced
but a not as much as we thought
and number two the
um bouncing back was extremely
surprising within just a couple of
months a lot of people were back to
their Baseline happiness so adaptation
is really fast you kind of find ways to
overcome these things that being said
that was like a bird's-eye view because
there were parts of the population that
were not doing well right so if you kind
of take a warm side view you see that
for example people with mental health
problems I mean pre-existing ones they
had trouble adapting to this new
situation
um some like women actually did a little
bit worse because they were probably had
more of the the child care
um
younger individuals did worse in older
individuals maybe because of that
u-shape
curve but in general people adapt faster
than they believe they will and I think
that goes back to our question of why
don't people take risks and why don't
write why don't they make changes I
think because one of the reasons is
they're afraid that they won't adapt to
the change right
and they underestimate how fast and how
well humans adapt to changes in their
environment and their situation I mean
this is basically why our species did so
well and why we're all
here today I think because we can just
adapt to to these different environment
changes and
when we're trying to get people to take
action in their lives or just take
action in teams and such one of the
things in the influential mind book that
you wrote talks about how um
fear and trying to scare people and I
was thinking about it then when you're
talking about the pandemic and much of
what the governments were saying and how
trying to get us to conform to the
pandemics through
um fear I guess
um should we try and scare people into
action as leaders yeah so so I really
like this because it's kind of a
fundamental neuroscientific uh finding
that it's a little bit of a leap but
tells you something really interesting
and how to get people to do something or
not to do something
so basically what we find is that if you
want to induce action it's more helpful
to highlight the rewards you know if you
do this you know if you put the time in
you know you're going to get a promotion
um unless so about the fear if you don't
do this you won't get a promotion so if
you want people to act
highlighting rewards highlighting the
good time the good outcomes is better if
you want people not to act let's say you
want them not to reveal some secret
actually highlighting the punishment is
better and why is that so this is where
I find it really interesting which is we
kind of evolved in a world that to get
something good whether it is a promotion
or love for we have to do something so
I'm thirsty I need to move my hand and
have a little sip of this
T right so and imagine it doesn't
necessarily this is a world we live in
but it it's not necessarily the way it
could have been it could have been that
to get the tea I'd have to kind of like
go like this and not do anything I
imagine like different physics or
something right but the world that we
live in is to get the good stuff you
have to do things and so our brain has
evolved in this kind of world where
anytime something good we anticipate
something good a go reaction is
activated deep in our brain in the
midbrain it goes all the way to our
frontal cortex and makes action more
likely
now the reverse is that if usually in
the world to avoid something bad usually
not always but usually we just need to
not do anything so whether it's deep
Waters untrustworthy people uh poison I
usually just need not to eat not to jump
in the pool right I need to just stay
put so our brain is evolved in this kind
of environment that to avoid the bad
things I need to not act and so when
there is anticipation of something bad a
no-go reaction is activated deep in our
brain goes all the way to frontal cortex
and it inhibits action
now again we're sophisticated creatures
we can overcome this but our immediate
reaction is to freeze in this case not
to flee or act right first we freeze and
then we might be able to do something
and so we see this in like very basic
studies where we tell people press a
button to get money or press a button to
avoid losing money they press the button
faster to get the dollar than to not
avoid losing it because action is
related to rewards right interesting so
it's hard for them to do to I mean of
course they do it but there's a little
bit of inhibition
if if the goal is to not have something
happen not to lose right we kind of I
mean a lot of I mean there's on one hand
there are these theories about fear gets
me motivated I don't want to lose that's
why I don't really believe that that is
the commonly true I think usually we do
stuff to get things rather than to avoid
losing things example in your book as
well is you think about planes going
down when people are most scared they
just they're frozen
and um fear doesn't necessarily seem to
be a great driver of
human action and motivation in the same
way yeah that's that's really important
for organizations that are trying to get
their people to take greater risks
um and to innovate and to take chances
which is to try and remove as much of
that fear as you possibly can right and
also to kind of be able to vividly
imagine this like goal this better
future
um again it's not because our whatever
we think in our mind is changing the
world but it changes your behavior
chapter six in your book is what happens
to people under threat and you talk a
lot about stress and the role stress
plays in organizations and companies now
I've gone back and forward in my mind
about the concept of stress because I
remember reading a lot that um some of
the most subjectively fulfilling jobs
were like quite stressful jobs it was
things like being a military commander
at the highest level because I guess
they have a lot of meaning associated
with them but what role does stress play
on people's
um behavior and actions as it relates to
you know workforces and teams and
relationships I'll actually start with
the kind of example that you're you're
talking about you're saying well a lot
of them really most filling jobs are
highly stressful
but I think the people who take those
jobs are somewhat resilient more to
stress than others right so how much
stress you're feeling is a subjective
thing right it's not only about what's
happening it's also about you so it you
know so you could have a what other
people will consider a very stressful
job
and you're maybe feeling a little bit
stressed and we know I mean I'm sure a
lot of people know this that the optimal
there's an optimal kind of inverse
u-shape for stress no stress at all is
actually not that great for your
performance and a lot of stress is also
not good you want to be somewhere where
you have a certain amount of stress
that's driving you forward but again
that certain amount of stress is the
subjective feeling of it it's not the
objective
um happening right
but what what kind of I talk about there
is um that what happens when when you
are stressed and when I say stress I
mean you're feeling stressed like
cortisol is going up and and you know
that people tend to concentrate on
negative information
so if we give people so this is kind of
interesting if we we I ask you like what
is the likelihood that you will sell
your company and you give me a number
um and I give you a number and I say you
know actually based on all my data
you're more likely to sell the company
you will listen to me you'll change your
belief but when I tell you actually
based on my num my my data you're less
likely to sell your company that you
believe you won't change it as much you
listen you'll learn a little bit but
you'll learn more when I give you the
good news so we talked about that a
little bit before good news is more
effective than bad news not under stress
so if you're stressed out for whatever
reason it doesn't have to be but a
business reason you could be stressed
because of the conversation you had with
your partner that will then affect how
you take the information that I give you
you will now focus more on the negative
information surprisingly negative
information that I give you than you
would otherwise will interesting um and
if you look at you know if you look at
events in in the world whether it's
after a terrorist attack or a pandemic
or natural disaster people get a lot of
this kind of information even if it's
not happening here there's a terrorist
attack halfway around the world we get
all the information on the media that
stresses us out the stress causes us to
focus more on the negative information
which of which there's a lot of at the
time and that can actually cause people
to be overly pessimistic so a lot of
times we're overly optimistic but
actually when really stressful things
happen we could be overly pessimistic
and you can see that in the market in
the financial Market
where when the market starts going down
even if it's a little bit it does cause
stress and then start people get overly
pessimistic they start panicking and
selling their stocks well really they
should be holding on so we get these
like overly pessimistic reactions under
stress because people start focusing on
the negative so they don't see the
evidence in the positive information
they kind of focus on the negative
information it's funny because the
example you gave in the context of
selling a company in a business I've got
a very close friend of mine who
pre-pandemic set valuation for his
company I'm going to say 100 million and
he was dead set on it he was you know he
wouldn't accept a penny less
post-pandemic and in the wake of the
like sort of economic backdrop we're
facing now recession he is desperate to
sell it for 20 minutes exact same
company it's weird how much his
perspective has changed from being this
person who is absolutely not willing to
budge the company's not changing the
company's as well as it was before but
just with the pessimistic Outlook he's
suddenly trying to offload the company
for fraction of the price and is
suddenly seems to be incredibly
desperate in doing that and I guess that
further reinforces your point about us
being much more suggestible
um and pessimistic in times of threat
and stress because now it's not likely
that there's any a buyer out there and
it's just interesting having observed
that in him so quick so quickly it seems
or it wasn't even print post pandemic
because in the pandemic the markets were
great it was about a year ago it's about
12 months difference
um that he's willing to drop the value
of his company by about 80 even though
it's doing really really well
um and then uh the one thing I think
about a lot in building companies and
Building Company cultures is the role
stress plays on like Innovation and risk
taking
um
it's interesting because most of the the
teams that I run
going back to social chain and even this
team and other teams that I'm I'm in
they are somewhat high pressure teams as
in like we're really we're usually at
the front of our Market we usually
um pushing very hard the growth is
usually very very intense but which
causes like imagine stress but at the
same time we're there and we need we'll
stay there by taking a high degree of
risks so how do I balance that
environment which can be stressful while
also needing people to continue to take
risks and innovate and feel safe in
doing so what advice would you give me
um so because we said that stress is
really stress is your own reaction
within yourself
um and that reaction can be different to
the same outside environment then what
you really want is to reduce people's
stress
and not necessarily not put the pressure
on them right I mean that's the better
right you could you could basically do
two things you could say oh put less
pressure on them I mean less give them
less work to do
um or on the other hand you could be
like well actually let's
stay with this amount of work but can we
just reduce the way that they perceive
it on the stress that they have
so I actually think my answer is going
to be extremely simple because the
research shows that simple things like
and this is so simple that I'm exercise
actually is great
at reducing stress
um I don't do things like meditation and
so on but but people
um there's studies showing that that
also reduces stress so
I actually think those are really
important going outside walking in
nature right social interaction so
there's all of these things that that
can reduce stress and I really believe
that just having in this kind of sounds
like really that's on but just working
out like an hour in the morning or
something like that is gonna hugely
change it reduces stress it makes you
more focused
um then if you want to do like something
more psychologically you can
highlight how you can get through it
right so okay so this is all the
workload and these are all the problems
that can there are hurdles these are the
problems either the hurdles but okay
let's think through how we go we
actually overcome them rather than just
put it out there right walk through
about what okay what are we gonna do in
order to get to where we want and then
the other thing that we talked about the
other a little bit ago is um progress
monitoring that's always helpful like
not just
saying that things are progressed if you
can actually like if there's a way to
see it right if there's an actual way to
like put it on a board or something like
that
um because again like just
um enhancing people's confidence and
optimism will reduce stress as well
these are two fantastic books I mean
they're right up my street they're
people will know from listening to this
podcast that all of this subject matter
about influence about the brain about
psychology optimism pessimism all these
topics are things that I I absolutely
adore so anyone that loves this podcast
should immediately go and check out
these books because they are real sort
of foundational books on on this subject
matter but what are you thinking about
next what are you what are you you know
you could write about anything I I think
because of your your huge broad
understanding of human beings there's so
many things you could write a book about
sales whatever what are you thinking
about next
um so the book that I'm working on at
the moment which
um probably will be out in about one
year in 2024.
um is about how is it that in fact we're
not noticing a lot of the things around
us a lot of the good things around us
and a lot of the bad things around us
and in fact the reason for it is a basic
physiological reason of how our mind
works every single neuron in our brain
actually
and what it is is that when something is
like constant doesn't change in front of
us we stop noticing it we stop feeling
it we stop responding to it so something
simple like you jump into a pool it's
really cold after a few seconds doesn't
feel that cold or
um there's like the refrigerator noise
it really bothers you because you just
walked into the room
but after a few minutes or maybe half an
hour maybe 10 minutes you stop noticing
it you go to uh I don't know like if
people still
um remember going to a bar and was full
of smoke before smoking with bands you'd
go in and you'd be like oh and then you
don't notice it anymore the reason is is
that's how our neurons work that's how
the brain worked the neurons will
respond to things that are novel new
just happened and after a while they
adapt and they stop responding
physically they just stop responding so
okay fine that's that's fine when it
comes to sound or smoke and so on but it
happens to everything it also has what
we call emotional adaptation so you meet
your partner and it's so exciting and
you're so grateful and you're really
kind of feel the love and so and it goes
down over time if they're constant if
they're with you you just don't notice
how wonderful
um you know what is around you you've
got a new job that you always dreamed of
and you're so happy but very very soon
you think oh you know what is the next
thing now that's not a bad thing the
reason that we do that is because we
want to progress best but it also makes
us a little bit less grateful and happy
and the flip side is the side that
people haven't noticed so much which I
think most of our book is which is about
the fact that we stop noticing the bad
things around us
um things like for example if you go as
we talked about a little before we
started you go on Twitter when you just
start at Twitter you know 2010 or
whatever you'd go on in it and you'd be
like oh this is terrible people are
um calling names other to other people
there's all this harassment online and
you're kind of you notice it and you're
and then you get used to it you don't
notice it anymore so whether it is
misinformation that that is around us
whether it is you know dishonesty
um even even things like the reason that
we don't really notice climate change
around us is because it's happening so
so so slowly and our brain doesn't
respond to things that are constant or
very very slow so
um or risk actually we have a whole
chapter about risk uh risk adaptation
right so how you get used to taking
risks and you don't notice the risks
anymore you underestimate the risks
because you get used to that one of the
things I was thinking so earlier when
you talked about how when you were doing
presentations on stage starting in a way
that feels novel is a way to kind of
bypass the mind's filter that that's
useful that's used to people coming up
on stage and saying hi I'm Tom from I
don't know innovativesales.com and I'm
going to tell you and then your brain
just goes okay we know what to do with
this filter and then generally in
marketing as well we have this term we
use a lot on our team where we'll say
the word wallpaper you don't notice
wallpapers there and so whenever a
message sounds like wallpaper we know it
becomes ineffective so when people do
podcasts like this they'll say things
like well I can subscribe now you've
heard that 10 000 times so it works on
no one I'm asking you to like And
subscribe but you've heard the phrase so
but if I say it another way if I say my
mom's got a message for you and then my
mum appears in her in her big wonderful
African voice and says this is my son's
YouTube Channel please do you know then
as instantaneously it bypasses the
wallpaper filter and you're like what
that but it and and then the second
thing I was thinking about when you
talked about that is how we become kind
of we lose gratitude for things in our
lives very quickly because we were
coming sort of desensitized and use the
example of our relationships
so how does one stop themselves from
becoming bored of their partner yeah
actually I
have answers but but um I I love your
examples I might use a few of them
and and I think I think what you're
saying and I'll talk about the
relationship in a minute but yes exactly
what you want to do is surprise people
right exactly what you're saying you
need the brain to be surprised me I
didn't expect that because what the
brain is trying to do at all times it's
actually trying not to be surprised the
brain is trying to model the world to
have an internal model of what's outside
so I can anticipate what's happening so
then I can react in time right I want to
know like whether it's going to rain I
don't want to be surprised in the rain
because I want to bring the umbrella
ahead of time so it's all about I have
the best model of the world in my mind
so I can predict what's happened so I
can react in Time ahead of time so
that's why we're not responding to
things that are unexpected because the
model in the brain already told us what
is about to happen and when you surprise
people that's when like the neurons go
and then it's attention right so um so
we actually talk um about relationships
and
um it seems that when you ask people
and this is from
um
I'm gonna mispronounce her name but uh a
well-known
um uh relationship expert and she says
that she's done studies and when you ask
people when do you feel most attracted
to your partner
they say one of two things either when
you see them in an unexpected way
something that you're not used to maybe
they're talking to some strangers maybe
they're on a stage doing something and
the second thing they say is when I'm
away and when I come back I mean I I
it's it's really resonating right it's
like I mean
I I feel that a lot like when I'm kind
of you know I've been away for a while
and I'm on the plane ready you know on
the way home and I'm like oh I can't
wait to see everyone again and you know
so um what that tells us is that we need
a little bit of distance I think that's
what it says right that in fact
um you might want to
be away for like a weekend for a day or
so on
um and that kind of causes what we call
like it's a bit tacky but we call it
sparkling like we're sparkling you're
like we actually got the term from Julia
Roberts my co-author happened to read
and uh interview with Julia Roberts and
she was saying how
her life I mean it's Julia Roberts of
course like rich and privileged and all
of that but she was talking about her
regular life and you know she has a
couple of kids and her husband and she
wakes up in the morning and there's
breakfast and she brings him to school
and then you know they go have a bike
ride and lunch and then picks up the
kids and she's like well if I did that
every day all day for years and years
and years I'd probably think it was
quite boring you know and not that great
but once in a few months she goes away
and does Her filming or whatever and
comes back and everything seems like
re-sparkle again right because it kind
of feels like new again so you want to
to make feel things feel like they're
new and one way to do it is just to take
yourself to another place now you could
say well maybe I don't have money to go
away for the weekend
well there's a few solutions for that so
this was interesting because doing covid
I got covered and so I had to go down to
the basement and so I had to spend you
know five days or a week in the basement
um first of all it wasn't that bad it
was like a little camping experience and
second of all when like the few days
were up I felt like my home life was so
amazing so you know I came out of the
basement
um but it turns out so there's a little
exercise
that Laurie Santos recommends who's a
professor at Yale and she says if you
just imagine for a minute like close
your eyes and imagine your life without
your partner without like the great
house that you have without like the
great job that you have like if you
really imagine it and think about it
like that then so you know like the fear
comes in and then when you kind of get
out of that you're like oh I appreciate
it right and I know you have to probably
do it more than two minutes a year but
and I feel that's so true when you have
kind of you know how you have a dream
you kind of wake up from this really
terrible dream where you lost your
partner or something like that and you
and you're like so appreciative and so
yeah yeah I've got reoccurring Jim of
being falsely imprisoned and I wake up
oh my God my freedom no but you what
you've described there is um me and my
friends have been talking about we call
it desire Management in our
relationships which is like actively
managing the desire because we have a
really good example in our in our
friendship circle of a friend who moved
in with his partner on the second day
and they didn't just move in together
they moved into hotel room in the second
day and they just this was coven or what
um it was during covert but she she
lived on the other side of the world so
in order for them to be together she was
going to have to fly across and stay
with him and it was basically their
second day they moved into a hotel room
together and
desire very quickly drops and you but
there's also this Collision of Lifestyle
so like oh my God you've left the toilet
seat up and you make the bathroom wet
and these kinds of smaller things which
also are have a huge impact on desire
but then you're held together in a hotel
room for three months barely knowing
this person desire in that early phase
of relationship should be you know it's
normally like a little bit exciting and
it's funny how that can kill desire so
quickly and then moving in and then
um another friend of mine moved in
straight away
with somebody and they work together
live on top of each other and I saw the
same thing so me and my friends came up
with this term called desire management
where it's act actually our jobs as a
sort of in a relationship to manage the
desire actively manage it and this means
obviously some people go for dates and
they try and keep things new and fresh
but one of the best ways that I do it my
relationship is um
my partner goes away all the time and so
do I and like she's been in India for
the last four weeks she got back
yesterday or the day before it's like
feels brand new again and she does it
all the time she's always flying away
somewhere I'm gonna go do this training
course in summer I'm like oh my God this
is amazing because then I really don't
but then also it's funny you said that
because um last night we were at our
Christmas party that's why everyone here
is a bit pissed still a bit slow and
some of them missing and um my
girlfriend was really really pushing me
to go up in DJ I've never really DJ'd
before but I've been learning for nine
months and she was like pushing she was
like we'll go get a there was a DJ at
the punch that will go get a USB stick
now we'll go put it on there and you go
up in DJ and I I noticed that when I
went I went home I put some music on I
came back to the party and I DJ'd I
could see
because it was seeing me in a new
context yeah right and it's a really
like high status probably quite
attractive context
um and conversely when she did her
breath work sessions in London and she
had this room full of 25 people and she
basically has them hypnotized like
they're crying and screaming and she's
doing this thing it was so attractive
for me to see that see her in this new
club it's almost like discovering a new
person because you also see that person
from The Eyes Of The Strangers to see
them right so they see them as someone
that they don't know that they're not
intimate with and you kind of maybe see
that you get that point of view
um well I can't wait to read that book
as well
we have a closing tradition on the
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're going to be leaving it for
so let me see people don't believe me
when I say this but I actually don't get
to see the question beforehand
um
okay
the question left for you is
can you describe what winning means to
you
so it's a catch because I think what
winning means to me is to get what I
want however as we just said once you
get what you want then you want
something else so
that's still the answer
thank you so much Sally you write the
best books you really do this
conversation has been one of my favorite
ever because you have a really
remarkable ability to deliver very
important information that's very actual
in people's lives
do the tied in with the story that makes
it seem um that connects an emotional
level but then also support it with
science and psychology so thank you so
much it's honestly a huge and I I don't
think it was super fun
I really really mean it fantastic
conversation and I I know already how
much my audience are going to appreciate
it because I can kind of predict because
we're kind of the same people me and the
audience so thank you so much for your
time tell it means a lot thank you for
having me
[Music]
quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero I I can't tell you over the
last I'd say over the last really it's
been about two and a half years it was
really um post pandemic how much my
health has become such a huge priority
in my life and I have this laser laser
focused on what I'm putting into my body
it's funny because as you get older you
can start to feel the things you're
putting into your body more and more and
more
um and if I if I put something into my
body especially things like gluten if I
put those things in my body I feel them
tremendously the next day my energy
levels my sleep and everything in
between huel has been probably the most
important partner in my health Journey
because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it most of my
team that are in this room with me
consume it and get the benefits of it
too so if you haven't already tried here
do so
if you see me wearing jewelry there's
one thing you will know for sure this
has been the case since before they're a
sponsor of this podcast is that I'm
wearing crafted jewelry their pieces are
my favorite they are my favorite and as
I said if you ever see me wearing
jewelry I guarantee you it's crafter
jewelry their new collection here is my
favorite ever it's the most affordable
brilliant versatile wonderful high
quality jewelry I've ever seen and as I
said the meaning of the pieces as you
can see if you look at some of these
pieces for me of course it's
interpretation but optimism
um Freedom those are the kind of hints I
get through and my favorite piece of
crafts of all time is actually a similar
piece to the one that Conor McGregor has
Conor McGregor has a crafted piece
um and it's of the lion if you're
looking for male jewelry and you're
looking for stuff that is high quality
that is high in meaning and that is
aesthetically beautiful and on Trend
look no further than crafted
[Music]
thank you
[Music]